[Musik]
die kommandoübergabe im steirischen
aigen im ennstal der scheidende
kommandant oberst andreas staudacher
übergibt an den all whites staffel
kommandanten oberstleutnant udo koller
symbolisch den schlüssel zum stützpunkt
in seiner ansprache betont kunasek die
wichtigkeit des standorts eigen und
verweist dabei auf die leistungen im
hoch schneeeinsatz anfang des jahres und
es sogar dieser fliegerhorst hier hat
auch in den letzten wochen wieder
gezeigt zu welchen leistungen die
bediensteten soldaten hier auch in der
lage sind und auch wie wichtig und
strategisch gut er hier auch ist das
heißt da dieser frage was bleibt
erhalten dazu bekenne ich mich und ich
freue mich auf die zukunft die wir
gemeinsam hier lagen haben wir das die
zukunft des fliegerhorstes gesichert ist
betont auch der neue kommandant udo
koller
das ist ein wunderschöner tag für mich
der fliegerhorst ist in frage gestanden
aber wir haben jetzt eine positive
zukunft in sicht
wir erwarten jetzt einen frühling
außerdem wurde er in aigen der dort über
ein halbes jahrhundert stationierten
hubschrauber eine art denkmal gesetzt